so just like before i'm going to let you
have a go at this one without my help
but i will give you one
tiny tiny knowledge this is a definite
integral
okay you're going to go from naught to 1
square root of 4 minus x squared what
shape is that by the way
square to format x-ray this is uh
semi-circle not just any circumstance
circle
it's a semi-circle with center at the
origin and it has a radius of two
cool so hopefully you have a picture in
your mind
of what this is going to calculate okay
that's going to be really useful
later on because we're not going to
solve this one we're going to solve it
two ways
in order to deal with this semicircle
right we need to introduce some kind
of substitution when you have a look
back at
the unit circle exactly right
we actually introduced a substitution
that would help us deal with something
right
if say for example you wanted to define
a point on the unit circle unambiguously
you could do that with a set of x y
coordinates right
x comma y two points oh sorry two
coordinates gives you
defines you immediately right but then
we said there's another way to do this
you could do with just one number
we call it a parameter right in the case
of the unit circle what is the classic
parameter that we use
yeah we would say well theta is the
parameter right
uh measured from anti-clockwise from the
positive real axis
and that gives you cos theta as the
x-coordinate
and sine theta as the y coordinate
so i'm just going to lay this as a bit
of a clue for you that when we're
dealing with circles
the trigonometric ratios are never far
behind
so unlike these questions where we
stayed very firmly planted in polynomial
land
okay you might need to use something a
little more exotic for this question
number three over here
it's a bit harder i will help you i
promise but see if you can make
some headway you've got a few choices
few options have a go if you hit a dead
end
don't be dismayed keep trying yeah
all right i think you're ready for us
to try and put this
together and as promised i'm going to
show you not just one way to do this
is because several of you have already
realized oh this is something we could
do because i gave you
a big fat nudge into this question year
12. i just wait till everyone's
on board and by the way even those of
you who've successfully got into an
answer
in your working i've noticed there are a
few assumptions that you may that i'm
going to draw out as we go through this
that could be problematic and we need to
just be cautious with her
so here's the substitution i made it was
not the only substitution you could make
okay going back to this mystery box idea
you know there's not just one path
through this
but this one works just fine for me and
it's quite convenient i introduced
two side theta um i actually have an x
squared in my
integrand so i've written this right out
the gate but then in order to worry
about all the rest of this how to change
number one the variable of integration
and number two
my boundaries i've then written this
working are you following
with this all right now just be cautious
right when you went
from here's my dx which i'm going to
substitute shortly
to here's my boundaries i'm going to
work with it right hopefully you noticed
that we have to be kind of cautious with
these right something's being implied
here that i have not written in the
question
has not written which is a domain
restriction around theta
is pi on 6 the only angle that satisfies
the equation
sine theta equals a half the answer is
of course not there's an if there are
infinitely many solutions right
um six five power and six and those
plus minus any integer multiple of two
pi right so we have to be cautious with
these things and
often you'll even see it in the exercise
um the question will provide you some
kind of restriction that tells you
yeah it's fine you can do this but you
still have to be cautious as you're
about to see
so let's see if your substitution went
okay
as you go to the next step this is not a
hundred percent necessary but i
highly encourage you to do the entire
conversion of a question about
x's into a conversion about a question
about use
in one fell swoop okay that means i've
got
a new boundary down the bottom just so
happens that this new battery is the
same as the old one
i've got a new battery at the top
and this is important by the way don't
sweep past this quickly
it is a classic error of extension one
and two students to just completely
forget
the um boundaries and integration um or
to even do them but then forget to
write them in a lot of students saying
i'll do it later right because i'm just
thinking about say this um
like where's all the main muscle work
going into into the actual integration
and this is like a side note right guess
what happens when you make a side note
you just forget to come back to it
entirely you've seen it hundreds and
thousands of times that's why i'm making
a big do that
i've changed my boundaries what do i get
underneath the square root
squared right i'll come back to this bit
under the radical sign in a second
here comes my dx so it's 2 cos theta
d theta and i feel good now my question
entirely about x's
is now i think i said used before it's
entirely about things okay
now why was it useful why was that clue
about the unit circle handy
when we were dealing with this
particular question well where you have
squares and square roots
a lot of the um pythagorean identities
kind of come along for the right if you
know how to use them right
so if you have a look at what you've got
here if i factored out the square root
of
that gives me a 2 which in fact i'm
going to write out the front as a 2
times 2 which is 4.
right what does that leave you with
underneath the square root
4 that's 1 minus sine squared
which is last i checked cos square
right now here is a point at which many
of you
have just gone to the next line and said
oh sweet i know what to do with this
right
but i need to make sure you're cautious
about this
what is the square root of a square
the square root of say absolutely right
okay so if i said the square root of x
squared you would not necessarily
get x you would get the absolute value
of x now as you mentioned before
talking about your choice of
substitution right some choices
are better and some are worse because
some will introduce to you
cases where you have to deal with this
range and that branch
now in this case we can actually by
virtue of this being a definite integral
it's why
i wrote that off that's why the first
two were indefinite and this one i said
i better give you some boundaries for
this right
i can actually deal with the fact that i
don't need an absolute value so it's
very similar to that long question we're
looking at earlier i can say
in this particular context it's going to
just be equal to cos theta
but why
it is b flat three right in the
particular values that we're interested
in the domain i'm interested in
um e equals zero theta equals pi over
six
what is cos theta going to be equal to
well you start up there at one
right and then you come down to well
what do you come down to three on two
route three and two so you don't
actually get to the intercept you have
to get to
pi on two before you start getting into
negative territory where you
have this other case okay so i need to
say this
you need to say this if you have not in
some part of your working
wrestled with this fact you have to
actually show this working right
since i have a domain restriction here
right i can actually say
for this one zero is less than or equal
to theta
which is less than oh i couldn't
increase that
that'd be okay right i can get to zero
that's all good
it's an acute angle and in the first
quadrant all of my trig ratios because
you're gonna not just use
sine of course in the future you might
use tan as well all my trig ratios just
stay nice and positive does that make
sense
you need to get used to pulling this
move because the time we often use these
trigonometric substitutions
is where you're doing the square root of
a square so please note it that's why
i'm
highlighting that all right so we've now
dealt with the fact that i've gone
not six i've got the square root of a
square but i'm just dealing with the
positive k so everything's fine
cos theta times cos theta gives you
cos squared and now we've turned this
successfully into an extension one
question
right you've got a double angle identity
that you can use in here
what is the appropriate double angle and
then
one plus cos two theta should do it
i should do it properly rather than do
the factorization in a single step
like so would you carry that those two
are going to go together
give me two i'm quite comfortable to do
this integration
at this point what am i going to get
remember
plus cosine two theta
yes from naught to pi
on six two's out the front help me out
let's just
bring this home i'm gonna have a plan
six
i'm gonna have half of what pi
yeah this is um sine of
pi on three which is root three on two
and i've got half of that so that's root
three on
four yeah right that was in my head
there's the upper boundary
here comes the lower battery minus zero
minus zero yeah just be careful by the
way this is one of the reasons why i
went to sine you could have chosen
cos right but this is one of those handy
ones where you put zero
you get zero which doesn't obviously
always happen
uh high on three plus root three on two
are you okay with that there's an answer
now i asked several of you as i was
wandering around
how confident are you this question you
know i always love to ask right how
confident are you that this
is correct um can we know
for certain we can but there's a lot of
places for silly errors to creep in here
so you know how we love talking about
how lazy mathematicians like to be i
said to you right at the outset like do
you have a picture in your mind of what
this is actually determined
it's an integral from not to one of a
particular part of a semicircle so what
kind of thing are we actually just
telling you
it's an area
isn't it can you see the area now i've
deliberately not
shaded the particular area because i'm
about to but in a particular way
to make it easier for us to determine if
i just shaded the entire area from
naught to one underneath the semicircle
underneath this part of the arc right it
will be a weird awkward shape
it'll be a weird and awkward shape that
we could not determine don't have a
formula for it it's not a segment it's
not a scepter
um it's some weak combination of this
right so how could we divide this up
neatly
to make an area or areas that are easier
to determine are you going forward um
divide the area between zero to one
making it as a right a right angle
what a rival triangle right angle
triangle okay
so have a think about this there's a
couple ways to dice this up but the way
morgan suggested it is
uh if we take this point on the
circumference join it to the
origin right what if you create it as
morgan suggested here is a right
angled triangle all right and then let's
go christmas
today um you've got up here this
sector right we know how to work out
both of these in fact they're so simple
i reckon we could do it
right now area equals uh let's do
let's do the right angle triangle shall
we i need a base and a height
i've got a base don't i what's the base
it's it's one
here this is a circle or a semi-circle
of radius
two so oh wow how convenient this right
angle triangle is a
one two three root three
triangle right this is one you have seen
and memorized probably
so i've got a base i've got a height
area is
base times height on two
okay with that then i have a sector
i've been dealt with these for a while
area of a sector
is half r squared theta right
half r squared theta i know what the
radius is i just need a theta which i
haven't got
like straight away but i can work it out
right it's a one two root three triangle
so can someone give me one of the angles
in this apart from the writing
which one would you like you can do
either
okay so i see a pi on three here right
so this angle in here the angle that i
want that gives me the sector
is the complement of that which is
pi on six pi over six so i've got
half r squared
sine of pi on six last i checked
pi on six was equal to sorry sine of pi
and six rather is
a half right
a half sorry about it right
um i think it's
[Music]
somewhere in my brain uh my half and my
two squared give me
2 times pi over 6 which is pi
on 3 does that look a bit familiar
do you remember when we were doing that
3d vectors question with spheres
and we're always like look for a simpler
way
always look for a simpler way there
isn't always such a dramatically
simpler way you're not going to
completely get away from these
trigonometric substitutions i promise
for example how could you very easily
modify this question
to make this method irrelevant
i could just change the limits or not
give you limits
right and then say like give you some
domain restriction so you can still do
this substitution
but still require you to get to some
primitive right so that would
remain remember this nice elegant method
didn't work but at least now i can share
so usually like question three the
domain
is given uh well
let me say this way right if the domain
is not given
you've got some cases to deal with right
and those questions will appear
uh in fact from memory if you sneak to
the end of your exercise you'll see one
where exactly this happens okay so you
can't always escape it
but where you can try